North Korean State media has reported at
least 50 deaths and some 1 million
people down with fever days after
acknowledging A covid-19 outbreak for
the first time for more than two years
the country had claimed it was Covet
free it had also refused to accept
vaccines from abroad for its population
expats were a looming catastrophe in the
secretive State and there have already
been offers of help from Neighbors China
and South Korea
[Music]
tedious antivirus program is full on its
dresses how Pyongyang is working to curb
its major outbreak of the virus and
Ayers interviews with people who
overcome covid or what the nation calls
fever trying to boost morale amid a
nationwide lockdown
I started giving paracetamol General
cold medicine and antibiotics every five
hours to my daughter
and her fever was gone after three days
doctors in North Korea are promoting the
use of paracetamol and traditional
Korean medicine as covet treatments but
many cannot get them
Kim Jong-un has now ordered the Army to
help distribute medicine saying Health
officials failed to stabilize Supply
but even the most timely medication
delivery might still be insufficient for
North Korea's fight against covet
most of his population is still
unvaccinated
North Korea previously refused vaccine
offers from the Kovacs distribution
scheme
experts say the country fears the
program's monitoring requirements would
expose it to International scrutiny
in addition to pyongyang's Major Ally
Beijing South Korea is now also offering
to help
I have repeatedly expressed my
willingness to always open the door to
humanitarian aid for North Korea without
political or military consideration if
North Korea responds to South Korea's
offer to provide Aid we will give full
support including covid-19 vaccines and
medicines medical equipment and health
personnel
since North Korea acknowledged its
Omicron outbreak last week dozens have
already died and a million others
sickened by the coronavirus with no
vaccines and little medication available
taking precautions has become the key in
North Korea's covet battle
I'm joining me now for more is Dr sojin
Lim she's a senior lecturer in North
Korean studies at the University of
Central Lancashire Dr Lim when we're
speaking about North Korea we are
talking about an unvaccinated population
weak Healthcare facilities and the
Omicron variant how serious could the
situation get in North Korea
everyone uh is the same situation like
it's about a little bit of speculation
at the moment because we don't know how
exactly the situation is like in North
Korea because for like last more than
two years there were no uh other
foreigners in North Korea who could
communicate with our side of the country
however from the media in the North
Korea it looks like there's something
going on but on top of that in terms of
the data
it looks very serious but at the same
time it's also a little bit doubtful
whether those High number the southern
high number of uh the positive cases are
true or there's some kind of discrepancy
in data but
it looks like there's something going on
seriously in North Korea
and lockdowns have been announced do you
think that is the only strategy North
Korea has to fight this outbreak or will
it be forced to seek help from abroad
from my point of view North Korea is
more or less following a Chinese uh
strategy as we see the in Shanghai you
know China imposed very harsh lockdown
strategy and North Korea has been in the
same on the same page like China but
it's quite shameful and because the
people in North Korea they really suffer
from this lockdown and now it will be
even harsher than better so because of
that now for example UNICEF or South
Korean government or the Biden
Administration in the states they try to
offer the vaccination and medical
services and hopefully North Korea
regime could take them and open the door
for the people
now for more than two years as you were
also saying earlier the country kept
insisting it didn't have a single covet
case and it's a claim that no one
outside of North Korea believed help us
understand the thinking here of Kim
Jong-un I mean surely he knew that
denying the problem wouldn't make it go
away
this that's true um if we think about
what happened before covid-19 Kim
jong-un's regime had a little bit of a
threat inside in terms of the
information influx or even cultural
influx from our side because through
their smuggling process people could
obtain the especially Korean popular
culture because South and North Korea
share the same language and many of the
population especially who could obtain
those um SD card or DVDs or USBs for
through their mobile phones so that they
can watch South Korean drama or listen
to the K-pop then they even mimicked the
way how South Koreans speak and they try
to follow the uh the Fashions of South
Koreans and in that way the North Korean
regime kind of was under threat because
people now knew that a North Korean
regime
is something wrong but because of the
coveted 19 it was really good excuse for
Kim jong-un's regime to close all these
doors and the smuggling and then people
access to the information so that's why
North Korea has been knocked down for
such a long time
now on the day that North Korea
confirmed its first covet cases that was
last week it also conducted missile
tests I mean why fire missiles when
there is a greater human catastrophe
staring you in the face
so that is very interesting point
because before in the past when uh Kim
jong-un's father was still alive the
North Korea used to use the tactic
called nuke for food so whenever they
test tested the missiles then you know
the uh for example this United States
provided the food Aid to calm them down
so for North Korea simply they haven't
had any engagement with the U.S after
Trump Administration and Biden has been
really indifferent in North Korea So
This Could Be A Way North Korea sends
out the signals
tell us or engage with us and we are
even now having this situation because
all of Southern North Korea announced
that the covid-19 situation so this
could be the sign from North Korean
regime that they may be willing to
engage with outside of the world but
because of the saving phase they will
approach outside their side so it's more
like they send out the signals outside
of the world that they could reach out
North Korean regime
very interesting we'll have to leave
there for the time being though sojin
Lim from the University of Central
Lancashire thank you so much
thank you